joining us now I'm delighted Molly
Hemingway Fox News contributor and
editor-in chief of the Federalist and
David shown former Trump impeachment
lawyer um David let's still let's start
with you on the on the legal case here
which I find extraordinarily weak what
do the people need to understand in
layman's terms about how lame this is
and how dangerous this is let me focus
on the danger of it because you've hit
the nail on the head with that and with
the word extraordinary this case is
brought under New York executive law 6
312 it's gives the Attorney General a
politically partisan elected official in
this case extremely partisan um
incredibly broad powers to ruin a life
ruin a career Etc um then the case is
assigned to a trump haing judge also
politically uh appointed uh politically
elected and if you uh read a news
article that appeared this weekend he's
shown a consistent antipathy against
Real Estate developers during his entire
career now many people say well why is a
judge deciding it not a jury the judge
said earlier today that that's not his
fault no one asked for a jury trial
that's a bit disingenuous it is true
that President Trump's lawyers could
have asked for a jury trial under
Section 4102 of the New York cplr their
rules however there's a case from 2011
that said under this executive law 6312
there was no right to a jury because
it's Equitable is asking for injunctive
Relief not damages that's simply not
true they're talking about stripping
Donald Trump of hundreds of millions of
dollars taking away a brand that's not
just a New York brand it's an
international brand but today at least
it seems the judge finally got a clue on
what's going on here because they tried
to take things back to 2011 and the
court of appeals said nothing before
2014 so we'll see how it plays out but
you're right it's extraordinarily
dangerous yeah well the appearance of
bias and and and just corruption in this
entire proceeding Molly um to keep uh on
this issue for a moment last night on 60
Minutes attorney general uh Garland
denied that there's any even a whiff of
bias in these prosecutions watch we do
not have one rule for republicans and
another rule for Democrats we don't have
one rule for foes and another for
friends we have only one rule and that
one rule is that we follow the facts and
the law and we reach the decisions
required by the Constitution and we
protect civil liberties Molly yeah this
was propaganda that was aired last night
in this interview with Meritt Garland
what we have right now Merrick Garland
is participating in the Democrat
campaign strategy of indicting trump you
know all over the place in the hope that
there can they can get quick convictions
and interfere in the election that is
objectively true they are participating
in this Democrat campaign strategy he
said that they don't have one rule for
for one group and one rule for another
you can just look at the Hillary
Clinton's situation when she was
Secretary of State not president when
she mishandled classified information
when she obstructed the investigation
they came up with an entirely novel
legal standard to Let Her Off The Hook
and then meanwhile go after president
Trump on these on on bid and and they're
still trying to deny that some people
that that it's even his laptop laptop
and at the same time that you know uh
the the Pres the sitting president has
issues here it is not it's just it's
just so absurd to say there's not two
standards when we're living through this
every single day and he should not be
allowed to have this kind of flippant
response to yeah well 60 Minutes was
just a a complete propaganda piece for
the doj and and people oh isn't isn't
that so nice that it's all evenhanded
and it's a real threat to the Republic
what we're going through people have
lost confidence in our department of
justice that's a very serious problem
the fact that Donald Trump is doing so
well not just in the Republican primary
but even in head-to-head matchups
against Joe Biden shows that the
American people do not view these
indictments as that's the damage they've
done it's like what the damage fouchy
did uh David to the public health system
in our country and this and and
everything that we had heard about the
pandemic now that was called into
question and now they're doing the same
thing with the doj but the Mueller's
former buddy Andy Weissman he doesn't
believe Trump even has a defense in this
case watch this in many ways this
trial's over um the judge has already
ruled on the first of the claims against
Donald Trump and his sons and his
businesses he's already lost um with
huge financial consequences um that this
judge has
imposed David you could sense the Glee
coming from that odious creature's voice
um your response I don't credit anything
that Andrew Weissman says I've had
experience with him he's the most
ethically bankrupt prosecutor I
personally have ever dealt with in my
view um so I don't credit anything he
says but one thing he's right about is
this judge has usurped the role of
experts in this case the judge lost all
credibility when he said maral Lago
should have been Val valued at $18
million he left out a few zeros there's
not a person on the face of the Earth
that would think maral laga was valued
at $18 million and therefore was
overvalued on its stated value that's
just one example but back to the you
know the timing you mentioned in your
opening monologue that's what proves the
point about this um the agenda going on
here Donald Trump's been in business for
decades built his brand around the world
it's not coincidental that this case is
brought with the four criminal
indictments that are now brought
election season there's nothing
coincidental about it it's all
intentional and we see all of the rules
suspended there are case there's case
law gansler case and others that say a
prosecutor can't speak this way to
influence the public all of the time
they get this J Attorney General James
and the district attorney in New York
have gotten away with anything they want
to say and then they you know scream
bloody murder and want to gag order they
put out these speaking indictments in
the cases oh Trump can't speak though
that's right Trump can't speak but they
they never shut their mouth Molly I mean
it's it's staggering and it's all based
on this belief that that Donald Trump
needs to have not just his own income
but the income of all of these different
people in his family destroyed because
they politically disagree with him
that's not American he doesn't deserve
to have a company or to have an address
in New York they want to drive him out
of New York City and drive him into
bankruptcy then put him in jail so we
can't become president I mean it is this
is crazy land but I think the people are
on to this Dave and Molly great to see
you both hey Sean Hannah here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else